when you think of japanese cuisine a few
foods come to mind sushi did you know
that salmon sushi is actually norwegian
yeah we did a story on that one
maybe you think of mochi we did that one
too
and tempura but guess what tempora is
actually a portuguese dish oh boy here
we go
the japanese tempura you know is done
two ways either with seafood or with
vegetables
right and the batter is light made with
cold water wheat flour and egg pretty
standard this tempura can be found
dating back to the end of the 16th
century in japan but as we know japan is
much older than that so why did it
suddenly show up the answer is portugal
around 1543 a chinese ship with three
portuguese sailors got off course and
landed in japan on tanegashima island
fast forward a bit and the portuguese
because of this happy accident are now
trading goods and arms with the japanese
then in 1639 the portuguese were kicked
out of the country a few things however
remained including a dish of battered
and fried beans called pachins de orta
one of the best spots in lisbon to get
paschins de orta especially
consistently
is now of course over the past 400 years
japan has put its own spin on the dish
but you know it's a fun fact next time
somebody in your group orders
la la tempura
[Music]